Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed and noble self-awakened one.
So I just say this is our inaugural Full Moon Day meeting.
I've always wanted to do this, but I've never found a way to do it.
So I was really happy when Magda suggested that I try it on this medium.
So I think we can keep this going.
luckily it's fallen on a Sunday and I'm inclined to in the future choose the closest Sunday to the full moon because that's most convenient for people.
In Sri Lanka they are public holidays, all the moons are public holidays so there's no problem in keeping the full moon itself there.
So my idea is that with every full moon we look at some of the teachings of the Buddha
And eventually throughout the year, we cover it all.
So I'm going to start with this lovely little trilogy, a virtuous circle of gratitude, generosity, and renunciation.
So starting with renunciation.
So the big...
problem here that can arise is confusing what it is that we're actually renouncing so remember the body is not our fault when the body has appetite then it has appetite and when you put something uh lovely sweet on the on the tongue it will taste lovely and sweet that's never the problem as you know the problem is our relationship to it which is wanting more
depending on it in order to establish a beautiful mental state.
Now, that's what we've really got to grasp.
We use the sense bases, not because they are just lovely in themselves, but because they are a way of creating a lovely mental state.
Hence, you might have a piece of toast in the evening just to raise your spirits.
Now, the unfortunate thing of that, of course, is that you have dependency.
And that dependency is what we call attachment.
And so there's a suffering there.
See, if there's no bread and there's no toast, well, it's misery, isn't it?
So when we click onto that, we become much more sensitive to this draw towards what is pleasurable.
And this renunciation...
is therefore is not to be confused with, well, the word they use is self-mortification.
In other words, blaming the body for our mental states.
So that's an important distinction to make.
We're not trying to get rid of the pleasures and joys of life at all.
And the Buddha himself did enjoy life.
He enjoyed taste, but he didn't greed for it.
That's what it says in the scriptures.
And this whole idea of renunciation will arise on two different types of grasping, which is one about our wealth and the other about our time.
So we can be greedy with our time, but not greedy with our wealth.
So we can be generous with our wealth, but if somebody asks us to do something for them, we shy off it.
and the other way around.
We can be very happy giving time, but if somebody asks us for a bit of money, we're not inclined to give.
So again, we have to look at that.
And this trilogy, this little virtuous circle of gratitude, generosity, and renunciation, it's not actually
taught in the scriptures themselves as a way to liberation.
This is more a commentary pointed out.
And this, of course, of course, directly with our daily life.
This is our daily life in our daily work in the way we are with people.
So if we can generate that virtuous circle, it's actually drawing us towards liberation.
So letting go of attachment and
Letting go of dependency is the path to liberation.
So you might say that the whole of the path is one of renunciation.
Because eventually you've got to renounce the sense of self.
That's the last thing to go.
This little idea that somewhere within us, we actually do believe ourselves to be this psychophysical organism, for want of a better word.
So that's this renunciation business.
Now, just to go to the front of the trilogy, this sense of gratitude.
Now, as you know, when you feel gratitude, it really is a heartwarming feeling, you know?
And when we feel this gratitude, we always want to repay it.
Now, if we spend some time just considering what we've received,
from our parents.
Our parents gave us our life, you know, our mothers.
When you think about that, you might have problems with your mother and your father.
In fact, somebody once asked, how do you know when you're fully liberated?
And they said, well, go and spend a week with your mother.
And then you'll know.
So...
So it may be that our general relationship is a bit fractious and so on and so forth, but you still have your life through your parents.
And the Buddha said that even if you were to carry them on your shoulders the whole of your life, you'd never repay them.
In fact, it's unrepayable.
And that's what you begin to realize, I think, when you contemplate everything that's been given to you, you know,
from your family from your friends the good deeds and the companionship of family and friends all this is given to you and then there's things like what society gives us all our education you know our parents could not have afforded most of our parents could not have afforded to educate us and it's the same way the social services we might not have needed them up until now but if
If we get old enough, you definitely begin to need them.
And of course, there's our health system.
You know, it's funny how you take something as a right and you just sort of presume that something isn't given because either you've paid for it through the national insurance or because it's taken for granted.
But how many times have you thanked your doctors, you know, thanked the dentist?
Now, the dentist I had here in Bishop's Castle was really good.
The front tooth here finally gave in and he put this false tooth in, you know, and it was pretty awful.
You've got to get used to it.
You couldn't eat nuts.
All the nuts got behind the tooth, behind the palate.
So you had to take it out and wash your mouth out and stick it back in.
And when I told him that it was a little inconvenient, he finally decided to give me a bridge.
And there it is.
It's absolutely fantastic.
And it's a case of recognizing all these gifts that people have given us.
If you bring to mind, for instance, the teachers, one or two favorite teachers that you've had, you know, it does fill the heart with a sense of gratitude.
And finally, of course, there's nature, just the earth that we live on, which we become more and more aware of these days.
Now, what gratitude does is it makes you want to repay.
And because you can't repay what has been given, you can't repay something that has been given to you freely, you have to find a substitute.
And that draws you towards just being generous ourselves.
And that moves us into this whole area of generosity.
Now, when the Buddha talked to lay people, he always began with generosity.
You know, he pointed out that even a thief can be generous.
You know, he's just taken something off you and he's very kindly given it to somebody in his family or friends.
So when we think about generosity, the ability to give without some idea of being repaid,
And that's quite difficult for us.
So we have to clarify the mind about that.
Now, there are certain times you give gifts such as Christmas, which is more like, you know, a little ritual reestablishing friendship.
You know, so you get your pair of socks and they get their pair of socks.
And that's fine.
Unless, of course, the pair that they've given you is obviously much cheaper than what you spent on the socks that you gave them.
So that's when the trouble starts.
So there's always a bit of bargaining going on.
It's always like a business, like in business, you see.
So if we want to have an act of pure generosity, then you have to listen to what's going on in the background of our minds about being repaid, about being adored because of our generosity.
So if you're going to give, for instance, a donation to a charity, and there are so many of them these days, you know, you have to sort of get yourself into that mental state where that's the only thing in your mind and heart that you are giving this in order to help somebody, right?
And there's no hope of repayment.
The charity is not going to give you any money back.
So you're doing it for just that purpose.
And when you do it for that purpose, that's when you act.
That's when you make the donation, whether it's by card or by cash, it doesn't really matter.
And then, of course, once you've done it, you'll hear these little voices, you know, like you are truly a very wonderful person.
Or you might get the one of, oh, that's too much.
What do you give so much for?
You could have...
So you have to be, you haven't been caught up in that, you see.
So you've not been caught up in Mara.
The Mara did not catch you there.
So you can let those thoughts disappear.
And if guilt comes, you have to point to it and say, well, that is false guilt.
Because when I actually made the action, my heart was full of generosity.
And the same arises when you do something for somebody.
So I think most people, I certainly do, is say yes too quickly.
So if somebody says, you know, I've moved into this new house.
It's actually happened to me.
I've moved into this new flat, you know, and we're painting it.
You know, would you like to, you know, come and give us a hand?
And I said, yeah, yeah, I'll come on Saturday, you see.
And then as I'm walking away, I'm thinking, what?
What have I given this Saturday away?
And in that case, at that time, I was, shall we say, advanced enough to actually make myself do it, to teach myself not to say yes.
You know, just because somebody asks something, you don't have to say yes.
And there's a point where you can actually reflect for a moment and then, you know, say yes.
So it's coming from a point of reflection.
You're not done it by habit.
So, again, that point of generosity is has to be there has to be a certain reflection about it and that you are doing it from the heart of goodwill and that you're not even expecting a thank you.
And that's very difficult.
You know, when I became a monastic, we're not supposed to say thank you.
I mean, I say it in the West because people get very upset.
But in the East, you're not supposed to, you don't say thank you.
You see, it undermines the person's gift.
That's the understanding.
Because if somebody gives something to you, they don't expect you to say thank you.
But if they expect you to say thank you and then you don't say thank you, then, of course, they feel very upset.
And that tells you that the gift is slightly corrupted.
They wanted praise.
They wanted appreciation.
So to be able to give something without that desire to be acknowledged is leading us towards a real pure heart generosity.
And the other little telltale is just to give that little bit more that pinches.
That little pinch is where you're truly being generous, where you're giving just that bit of extra time, just that little bit of,
extra money and that's the point where where it just begins to hurt a little bit you know that's that's the point where you are truly extending your extending our generosity so just to recap you we have this lovely virtuous circle general this this feeling of gratitude and
One exercise you can give yourself is just to say that tomorrow, everything, I will say thank you to everything.
I'll say thank you to the door that opens.
In Zen, of course, you're always gassho when you enter a room.
You're taught to thank everything.
You have to gassho when you approach the table.
You gassho to the chair.
So this whole attitude of actually not presuming on anything, not thinking that we have a right to everything, but that everything is a gift.
And if you go through the whole day like that, you'd be surprised how it lifts you.
It really does lift you.
And then once you've established, once we've established more and more this sense of gratitude and the knowledge that you can't repay directly what people have given to you.
There has to be, you have to find a way of expressing that gratitude through generosity.
And when we are being generous, you know, just to stop for a moment and to make sure that you're doing it for pure reasons.
That's all.
And then to realize that when I've actually made an act of generosity with a pure heart, I've renounced something.
I've let go of something I'm holding on to.
And I'm actually practicing renunciation, right?
Letting go of that grip on things.
And that loosening of a grip, that letting go of these tight desires, wrong desires,
is a little, every time we do that and we feel that loss of grippiness, that in a sense is a touch of divanā because one of the descriptions of divanā is that it is desireless of these sorts of wrong desires.
So there's a lovely little practice there which, you know, is just ongoing.
day in and day out.
And it's only a matter of reminding ourselves to do it.
And just very slowly, it becomes a habitude, that's all.
And really, that's what we're doing in our practice.
We are just changing our habits, moving away from habits which cause ourselves suffering and aren't very pleasant for others, and moving towards habits which bring us happiness.
So there is
you know, the gift of the practice is a natural happiness in life.
It's not Nirvana, it's just a natural happiness.
And this happiness that we talk about is the internal environment, you know, within ourselves.
So this is a really powerful practice.
And I try and remember to do it myself occasionally.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
that they have not caused even greater confusion and that you will, by your practice, become liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.